A TAIL.
THESE GUYS HAVE AIM.
HERE'S JEANNE MOOS.
>> THERE IS A RUMBLE IN THE
STREET.
MAN, NOT TWO GUYS LIKE THAT.
TWO GUYS LIKE THIS.
♪
NO WONDER THE MAN WHO SHOT THIS
PUT IT TO MUSIC FROM THE
NUTCRACKER.
THAT SEEMED TO BE WHERE A LOT OF
THE KICKS LANDED.
TWO MALE KANGAROOS, BOOMERS
THEY'RE CALLED, FIGHTING FOR
DOMINANCE OR FUN, SUBURBAN
SETTING NORTH OF SYDNEY,
AUSTRALIA.
IT IS NOT SO MUCH LIKE BOXING,
BUT RATHER ULTIMATE FIGHTING.
NATGEO WILD DESCRIBED IT THIS
WAY IN THE WORLD'S DEADLIEST
SERIES.
>> A FAVOR TACTIC, USING THE
FOREPAWS TO GRIP THE OPPONENT
AND THEN QUICKLY KICKING WITH
THE HUGE CLAWED HIND FEET.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO SEE THEIR
COOLEST MOVE, WATCH THIS.
AS HE RAISES HIS LEGS TO KICK,
FREEZE IT, STANDS ON HIS TAIL,
MOMENTARILY SUPPORTING HIS WHOLE
BODY ON THAT BONY MUSCULAR TAIL.
THEY FIGHT LIKE A SILENT PAIR OF
DINOSAURS, FROM JURASSIC PARK.
QUIET, BUT DEADLY.
A TRAINED BOXING KANGAROO NAMED
KILLER WILLARD TOOK ON HIS
HANDLERS DURING A DEMONSTRATION
AT A CLEVELAND TV STATION.
>> WAIT A MINUTE.
THIS IS MY HUSBAND.
>> Reporter: NOW WHO IS THE LAST
GUY YOU WOULD EVER IMAGINE
BOXING A KANGAROO.
>> YOU'RE GOING TO WATCH ME
FIGHT, AUSTRALIAN LIGHT
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION.
>> Reporter: IT IS A YOUNG WOODY
ALLEN, SEEMED TO MESMERIZE HIS
OPPONENT IN THE '60s VARIETY
SHOW.
WOODY THREW A FEW PRETEND
PUNCHES.
THE BOOMER LUNGED, HAD WOODY IN
HIS CLUTCHES, BUT NO HARM DONE.
SAME GOES FOR THE BRAWL IN
AUSTRALIA.
SEEMED PRETTY MUCH A DRAW.
ONE KNOCKDOWN, BUT NO KNOCKOUTS.
BUT WHO NEEDS A LEG TO STAND ON
WHEN YOU'VE GOT A TAIL?
JEANNE